HERE I THINK WE HAVE A QUORUM
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
LEYVA HERE LEYVA HERE WILK
PRESIDENT WILK HERE CHIANG.
CHAIN HERE THE RUSSELL.
LASSO HERE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU WILL WELCOME
TO TODAY'S SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WE HAVE SIX BILLS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY TWO ITEMS ARE
ON CONSENT.
SB FIFTY TWO WAS CENTER ATKINS
AND SB THREE SIXTEEN BY SENATOR
RUBIO WILL BEGIN WITH A SPECIAL
ORDER TO HEAR SB ONE THIRTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR ROTH SENATOR
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MORNING
MEMBERS [inaudible]
PLEASE ABSOLUTE.
WE GET ORGANIZED HERE.
FIRST LET ME EXCEPT THE FIVE
AMENDMENTS.
OFFERED BY THE COMMITTEE AND I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE OF SHOWN
CHANEL MATT NEED FOR A JOB --
EXTRAORDINARILY WELL DONE ON THE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU.
THIS BILL IS A SIMPLE BILL BUT A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL THAT
REQUIRES SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
WORK WITH THEIR RESPECTIVE K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS TO
IDENTIFY THE BEST METHOD. TO
INFORM BOTH PARENTS AND STUDENTS.
ON WHAT IS A VERY VERY DANGEROUS.
IF MISDIAGNOSED OR UNDIAGNOSED
DISEASE TYPE ONE DIABETES.
AS YOU MAY KNOW TYPE ONE
DIABETES IS AN AUTO IMMUNE
SYSTEM DISEASE THAT ATTACKS THE
PANCREAS.
PREVENTING IT FROM MAKING
INSULIN.
WITH THE LACK OF INSULIN A RISE
IN BLOOD GLUCOSE QUICKLY CAN
LEAD TO SERIOUS HEALTH PROBLEMS
INCLUDING DEATH.
WELL WE TYPICALLY DO NOT REQUIRE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE THIS
TYPE OF INFORMATION I BELIEVE
AND WE BELIEVE IN THIS CASE IT'S
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO DO SO.
AND THIS BECAUSE TYPE ONE
DIABETES CAN BE VERY VERY
DIFFICULT TO DETECT PARTICULARLY
IN CHILDREN. FIVE AND UNDER.
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS WHO
FREQUENTLY CAN'T TELLUS.
WHAT'S WRONG.
IT IS IMPERATIVE HEARD OF THE
PARENTS AND STUDENTS ARE AWARE
OF THE TYPES OF SYMPTOMS.
AND SIGNS I HAVE THREE WITNESSES
WITH ME TODAY TO PROVIDE SOME
BRIEF REMARKS.
BRET MICHAELS WHO I THINK YOU
JUST HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO MEET.
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION MEMBER
AND OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE FORMER
STATE SENATOR TED GAINES.
AND MY CONSTITUENT.
OF VERY VERY -- PASSIONATE TYPE
ONE DIABETES EDUCATION ADVOCATE
[inaudible]
DAVID GEORGE.
SO TO LEAD US OFF WITH THE
PERSONAL ACCOUNT.
MADAM CHAIR.
MR BRET MICHAELS AND FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO.
DID NOT GOOGLE HIM AND IT DID
NOT PURCHASE ONE OF THE FORTY
PLUS MILLION ALBUMS HE SOLD.
HE IS A SUCCESSFUL VOCAL ARTIST
ENTREPRENEUR AND PHILANTHROPIST.
WHO MANY MAY NOT KNOW?
HAS DEVOTED A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF HIS WELLS.
AND HIS TIME. TO EDUCATE.
ON THE ISSUE OF TYPE ONE
DIABETES VENTURE.
MISTER MICHAELS WELCOME PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY.
I JUST WANT TO SAY IS A TYPE ONE
DIABETIC -- SINCE THE AGE OF SIX
AND NOW AT THE AGE OF FIFTY SIX
IT IS SO IMPORTANT THIS THIS
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY EIGHT TO
PASSAGE THROUGH.
EDUCATION AND EMPOWER MAN IS
EVERYTHING AND FOR ME AS A CHILD
I WAS DIAGNOSED.
AT THE AGE OF SIX AND WAS
EXTREMELY EXTREMELY SICK AND NO
ONE UNDERSTOOD WHAT IT WAS
BECAUSE THERE'S NO EDUCATION ON
IT.
ANDSO YOU KNOW AS A DIABETIC
YOUR BLOOD SUGAR LEVEL CAN RISE
EXTREMELY HIGH.
MINDED UP TO ALMOST EIGHT
HUNDRED WHICH WAS PRETTY MENDOZA
KETO ACIDOSIS LEVEL.
BECAUSE OF THE ON EDUCATION ON
IT AND MY FAMILY.
AS MUCH AS A LOT ME THOUGHT I
HAD THE FLU OR DE HYDRATED
MISDIAGNOSED BY THE SCHOOL NURSE
DOCTORS AND AGAIN.
GOES BACK -- TO IT WHEN I GOT TO
THE HOSPITAL I SPENT ALMOST.
ALMOST A MONTH IN THE HOSPITAL
ONCE A DIAGNOSED AND WERE ABLE
TO START TO CORRECT -- THE HIGH
BLOOD SUGAR LEVEL AND IT IS A
VERY VERY DEADLY DISEASE IF LEFT
UNDIAGNOSED.
AND I THINK IT IS SUCH A STRONG
BUILD THIS BILL TO EDUCATE.
AND LET EVERYONE KNOW -- IF YOU
HAVE AN EMPOWERMENT AND AND NOT
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE TALK ABOUT.
ANY ABILITY TO EDUCATE PEOPLE
AND I'M GOING TO BE ABLE TO
CHECK THEIR BLOOD SUGAR COULD BE
AS SIMPLE AS A A FINGER STACK.
AND SHOWS ANY KIND OF ELEVATED
LEVEL AT ALL.
IT GIVES THEM A CHANCE TO
IMMEDIATELY BE ABLE TO PREPARE
THEMSELVES TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
AND LIKE HE SHIRTS SAYS IN OUR
CAMPAIGN IF YOU KNOW.
RIGHT HOW KNOWLEDGE IS IS POWER --
NEXT IS BEING ABLE TO SURVIVE
THAT IMPACT BECAUSE NOT JUST
IMPACTS THE CHILD WITH JUVENILE
DIABETES THE WHOLE FAMILY
EVERYBODY IS IMPACTED RIGHT.
AND AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN --
TO BE ABLE TO THRIVE YOU WANT TO
LIVE AN UNBELIEVABLY GREAT LIFE
YOU WON'T HAVE THAT CHANCE.
AND I SAY PLEASE CONSIDER THIS
SO THAT WE ARE NOT VICTIMS BUT
VICTOR'S.
VERY MUCH MISTER MICHAELS.
SENATOR GAINES WELCOME NICE TO
CO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY COME AND TESTIFY FOR
CENTER ROSS BILL THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- IT'S SO
CRITICAL AYE MY STORY -- IS --
INTERTWINED WITH POLITICS -- IT
WAS BACK.
ALL ABOUT -- EIGHT YEARS AGO NOW
NINE YEARS AGO -- I WROTE WHAT'S
IN THE ASSEMBLY AROUND FOR THE
STATE SENATE -- MY WIFE -- RAN
FOR THE ASSEMBLY [inaudible]
AND ONE THAT RACISM WAS BEING
SWORN IN AND WE WERE AT THE
CAPITOL -- DURING THAT CEREMONY --
MY SON TEDDY -- AND OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS WERE AND THAT'S OFFICE
SAID SHE WAS GOING TO TAKE AFTER
BEING SWORN IN.
AND TEDDY CAME.
RUNNING TO US AND SAYING -- SAID.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S WRONG WITH
KELLY BUT SHE'S LIKE THIS.
BLUE PURPLE COLOR AND SHE'S
COLLAPSED ON THE DESK.
IN THE CAPITOL OFFICE SO -- WE
WENT TO THE NURSES STATION AND
THEY SAID YOU KNOW THIS COULD BE
TYPED IT IT DID THIS BUT WE'RE
NOT SURE.
WE RECOMMEND SHE HAS THE ARE SO.
WE CALL HER DOCTOR DOCTOR SAID I
ONCE YOUR FIRST BEFORE SHE GOES
THE ARE -- OUT WITH THEM TO THE
DOCTOR TWICE AND THIS IS BEEN
MISDIAGNOSED AND I I DON'T BLAME
THE DOCTOR I THINK IT'S AN
EDUCATION RELATED ISSUE.
BUT WE DIDN'T HAVE HER BLOOD
CHECKED TWICE BUT IN THOSE BLOOD
TESTS.
IT DID NOT INCLUDE THE GLUCOSE
LEVEL AND THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
THAT WOULD HAVE TOLD US
IMMEDIATELY.
SO -- WE ADMITTED HER INTO THE
HOSPITAL SHE WENT INTO I SEE YOU
FOR SIX DAYS -- HEARD GLUCOSE
LEVELS OVER EIGHT HUNDRED WHICH
IS VERY HIGH I MEAN IT SHOULD BE
BETWEEN EIGHTY AND A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY IN THAT.
IN THAT RANGE.
AND SO -- THE ABILITY TO KNOW
WHAT THE EARLY SIGNS ARE -- I
WISH WE HAD KNOWN BUT THE DOCTOR
SAYING IT.
LOOKS LIKE MAYBE SHE HAD A COLD
AND SHE'S RECOVERING FROM A COLD
AND THAT SHE SAID MAYBE SHE'S.
DEPRESSED BECAUSE YOUR MOM'S
GONNA BE WORKING THE LEGISLATURE
WE'RE GOING.
NOTE THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE AND SO -- SHE
WAS -- CONSTANTLY THIRSTY -- SHE
WAS FOR RATIONS INNER APPETITE --
SHE WAS WAITING YOUR BED AT AGE.
EIGHT OF THESE THINGS THE STINT
WERE MAKING ANY SENSE SHOULDN'T
HAVE THE ENERGY TO BE CARRIED AN
FOR THE DOCTOR LATER AYE.
I HELPED HELPED HER COMMENT. TO
MEET THE DOCTOR THE SECOND TIME
SO.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT SHE'S WITH
US IN THAT SHE'S THRIVING AT AGE
SIXTEEN SHE'S A JUNIOR -- SHE'S
VERY STRONG IN MATH AND SCIENCE
AND WANTS TO GO IN THE FIELD OF
MEDICINE.
I'M SURE THERE'S A CORRELATION
THERE.
SO -- JUST THANKFUL FOR SENATOR
RALPH AND FOR THIS BILL --
HOPEFULLY MOVING FORWARD.
OFFER A SIMPLE ARE GLUCOSE A
BLOOD TEST THANK YOU.
THE CENTER GAINES WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME I APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK I'M GOING
TO READ SOMETHING THAT I TYPED
UP I HOPE YOU DON'T MIND.
SO MY NAME IS DEBBIE GEORGIA MY
SON DYLAN HAS TYPE ONE DIABETES.
DON WAS DIAGNOSED AT TWENTY FIVE
MONTHS OLD AND HE IS NOW
SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD AND A JUNIOR
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
TYPE ONE DIABETES IS A
MANAGEABLE DISEASE IF PROPERLY
DIAGNOSED IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THE PROBLEM IS AS YOU'RE HEARING
IT USUALLY TAKES TWO OR THREE
VISITS TO THE DOCTOR BEFORE
PERSONS PROPERLY DIAGNOSED.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED TO
MY PRECIOUS BABY BOY ONE VISIT
TO THE PEDIATRICIAN.
AND TO VISITS TO URGENT CARE
BEFORE MY SON WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
TYPE ONE DIABETES.
BY THIS TIME DON'T HAVE A BLOOD
SUGAR LEVEL OF FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY EIGHT HE WAS IN DIABETIC
KETOACIDOSIS AND HAD COLLAPSED
VEINS DUE TO DEHYDRATION.
HE WAS IN THE HOSPITAL FOR FOUR
DAYS GETTING HIS BLOOD SUGAR
STABILIZED.
I WILL NEVER FORGET THE NURSE
TELLING ME.
IT'S A GOOD THING YOU GOT HIM IN
HE MAY NOT HAVE SURVIVED THE
NIGHT.
IT WAS THE MOST TERRIFYING GUT
WRENCHING FEELING TO THINK I
COULD HAVE LOST MY PRECIOUS SON
AND ALL BECAUSE OF HIGH.
NOR TO THE DOCTORS KNEW THE
SYMPTOMS TO THE ONSET OF TYPE
ONE DIABETES.
OVER THE YEARS THERE BEEN MANY
ADVANCEMENTS IN THE MANAGEMENT
OF TYPE ONE DAVE DIABETES WHICH
IS WONDERFUL.
BUT SADLY THERE BEEN NO
ADVANCEMENTS IN EDUCATION FOR
AWARENESS ON THIS DISEASE.
CHILDREN AND ADULTS ARE STILL
GOING UNDIAGNOSED ENDING UP IN
SOME CASES WITH LIFE THREATENING
COMPLICATIONS AND EVEN DYING.
THIS MUST AND TOO MANY CHILDREN
ADULTS ARE DYING FROM IT A
MANAGEABLE DISEASE.
BECAUSE PEOPLE WITH TYPE ONE
DIABETES ARE CONSIDERED TO BE A
MINORITY OF THE DIABETIC
POPULATION THERE IS A LACK OF
EDUCATION AND PUBLIC AWARENESS.
WE SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO GET AN
ACCURATE NUMBER OF PEOPLE LIVING
WITH TYPE ONE DIABETES IN ORDER
TO PROVE THIS MINORITY GROUP IS
GROWING AND GROWING FAST.
THIS IS AN AN INCREDIBLY
FRUSTRATING.
IN FACT ONE OF THE BIG DIABETES
ORGANIZATIONS WEBSITE STILL
STATES THE SAME STATISTICS THEY
HAD LISTED FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
WHEN MY SON WAS FIRST DIAGNOSED.
IT'S TIME THE PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS
THAT DIABETES IS NOT A SINGLE
DISEASE AND SHOULD NOT BE LUMPED
TOGETHER AS SUCH.
KNOWING THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
TYPE ONE AND TYPE TWO DIABETES
CAN BE THE DIFFERENCE LITERALLY
BETWEEN LIFE AND DEATH.
EDUCATING THE PUBLIC TO OUR
SCHOOLS WILL RAISE AWARENESS TO
THE SYMPTOMS OF TYPE ONE
DIABETES FOR PARENTS GUARDIANS
AND CARE GIVERS WHICH CAN HELP
DETECT AND EARLY DIAGNOSIS.
RAISING AWARENESS IN SCHOOL IS
CRUCIAL BECAUSE TYPE ONE
DIABETES AFFECTS MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS.
IF STUDENTS ARE AWARE OF THE
SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS OF TYPE ONE
DIABETES SUCH AS HYPERGLYCEMIA
WHICH IS A HIGH BLOOD SUGAR OR
HYPOGLYCEMIA LOW BLOOD SUGAR.
AND KNOW WHAT TO DO TO HELP A
STUDENT WHO MAY BE IN DISTRESS
THEY COULD POTENTIALLY SAVE A
LIFE.
RAISING AWARENESS WILL ALSO
BRING COMPASSION AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS AUTOIMMUNE
DISEASE WHICH WILL HELP AND THE
STEREO TYPES AND BULLYING THAT
MAY COME TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
DIFFERENT.
AS A MOTHER OF THIS OF A SON
WITH TYPE ONE DIABETES AND
FOUNDER OF THE EASTYOU WENDY
TYPE ONE DIABETES AWARENESS.
I FULLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY EIGHT I THANK SENATOR
ROBB FOR AUTHORING THE AUTHOR
AUTHORING THIS LIFESAVING
EDUCATIONAL BILL.
AND ARE ON A ROLL CALL HONORABLE
CONNIE LEIVA AND SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
URGE YOU TO VOTE BY.
ON THIS MEASURE AND HELP US
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ON TYPE ONE
DIABETES LET'S SAVE LIVES
TOGETHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS GEORGE THANK YOU
FOR SHARING YOUR STORY.
WITH OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
HI CHRIS TAPIO I'M ON THE BOARD
OF JDRF SINCE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN THE CHAPTER AND
THE FATHER OF A SON WITH TYPE
ONE DIABETES AND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THIRTY ONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING MANSER ROB
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE BUT
SKEWS ME LET'S TAKE IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
BUT I THINK EVERYONE IS PRETTY
MUCH IN AGREEMENT THAT THIS IS A
GREAT BILL SO WE'RE GOOD OKAY
SENATE ROTH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
CLEARLY LACK OF AWARENESS AND
EDUCATION ON THIS ISSUE CAN COST
A LIFE.
AND IT HAS.
WE MUST GET THE WORD OUT AND WE
MUST DO IT NOW -- LIVES DEPEND
ON IT.
IN CALLING SAYS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HELP.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH TO HAVE
SOMEONE MAKE A MOTION FOR THE
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM ONE SB ONE THREE EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA HI Là I
WILL HI WILK I CHIANG HI CHIANG
I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE. SIX ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU CENTER
RODDICK YOU MADAM CHAIR COATINGS.
BUT WE WILL LEAVE AN ON CALL
[inaudible]
WHO ARE?
OKAY WE'RE GONNA.
WE HAVE A CLOSE.
SENATOR GLAZER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL
.
THAT ARE GLAZER WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY OKAY AT THANK YOU CHAIR
LEYVA AND MEMBERS.
AT FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH ME AND MY STAFF --
ON THIS ISSUE.
I AM PLEASED TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE SIX OF THE
ANALYSIS -- THAT DO REMOVE THE
TUITION FREEZE PREVENTION AND
ALLOW STUDENTS TO RECEIVE A
GRANT AWARD BASED ON THE
ELIGIBILITY OUTLINED IN FOR CAL
GRANTS AND AND FOR PELL GRANTS.
AS AMENDED -- THIS BILL CREATES
INCENTIVES TO ENCOURAGE
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM.
THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM
WHICH WENT INTO EFFECT IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN GAVE
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO GRADUATE IN
FOUR YEARS TO TOOLS TO HELP THEM
DO SO.
SO FAR NEARLY EIGHT THOUSAND
HAVE PARTICIPATED.
ARE THE PREVIOUS BILL CREATING
THE PROGRAM REQUIRED THIS CSU TO
SUBMIT A REPORT WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS.
ON POTENTIAL INCENTIVES THAT
COULD ENCOURAGE STUDENT
PARTICIPATION -- GOING FORWARD
THEY'VE DONE THIS.
IN THEIR REPORT THEY NOTED THAT
EFFECTIVE INCENTIVES -- QUOTING
COULD ENCOURAGE MORE STUDENTS TO
KEEP PACE WITH THEIR COMMITMENTS
AND COULD SERVE AS A MEANS TO
ATTRACT MORE STUDENTS TO COMMIT
TO THESE PROGRAMS AT THE ONSET
OF THEIR ACADEMIC CAREERS.
BUILDING UPON THE CS USE
RECOMMENDATION.
AND COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THIS
BILL WOULD ESTABLISH THE STUDENT
SUCCESS IN ON TIME COMPLETION
FUND.
ALLOW MORE MONEY TO BE
APPROPRIATE TO THIS FUND BY THE
LEGISLATURE ONLY BY THE
LEGISLATURE. TO BE USED FOR
SUMMER TERM GRANTS AND ON TRACK
PROGRESS GRANTS.
STARTING JULY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY IT WOULD PROVIDE --
BACK IN TUITION WAIVERS FOR ALL
REMAINING CLASSES NEEDED TO
GRADUATE WHEN A CAMPUS IS UNABLE
TO PROVIDE A PATHWAY TO GRADUATE.
IN FOUR YEARS SO TO BE CLEAR ON
THIS THE BILL HAS ONLY ONE
MANDATE AND EVERYTHING ELSE IS
OPTIONAL.
THE MANDATE IS IF A STUDENT CAN
GET A CLASS THAT THEY NEED TO
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS AND
THEY'RE IN THE PROMISE PROGRAM.
UNDER THIS LEGISLATION THE
UNIVERSITY WOULD PROVIDED AT NO
COST AND THAT'S A PROVISION THAT
SUPPORTED BY THE UNIVERSITY --
EVERYTHING ELSE IS OPTIONAL THAT
REQUIRES THE TRUSTEES -- THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THE
PRESIDENTS OF THE CAMPUSES AND
OF COURSE THE LEGISLATURE.
WHICH WOULD NEED TO FIND THESE
ADDITIONAL ENHANCEMENTS --
FINALLY THE ME JUST SAY THAT --
THAT WE HAVE SO MUCH -- TO BE
PRIDEFUL ABOUT OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM AT EVERY LEVEL
THEY DO SO MANY AMAZING THINGS
FOR OUR STUDENTS -- AND THEIR
FAMILIES -- AND WE WE FOCUS A
LOT ON ACCESSIBILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY AND QUALITY.
BUT THE ONE PLACE THAT WE
HAVEN'T PAID ENOUGH ATTENTION IS
STUDENT SUCCESS STUDENT
COMPLETION TO A DEGREE. THREE
YEARS AGO THE FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE AT THE STATE
UNIVERSITY BUT IT'S 19%.
CUT THROUGH IN FOUR YEARS.
ODDS IT'S UNACCEPTABLY LOW AND
THAT'S WHY THE LEGISLATURE ACTED
IN THE GOVERNOR ACTED. TO
PROMOTE THESE PROMISE PROGRAMS
IS FOR YOUR GRADUATION RATE
PROGRAMS.
I AM PLEASED WITH THE GREAT WORK
AT THE FACULTY AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THE CURRENT FOUR YEAR GRADUATION
RATE TODAY IS AT 25%.
AND THEY SET A GOAL TO REACH 40%
BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THESE
INCENTIVES IN THIS LEGISLATION I
AND OTHER THINGS THAT WE'RE
DOING -- IN THE SYSTEM I THINK
ARE REALLY GOING TO MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE FOR SO MANY AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THE BILL TODAY.
PLEASE TO HAVE WITH ME I HAD A
BRAG STAFF FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND
LOOK FOR HER TESTIMONY.
YOU CENTER GLAZER WAS BRAG STAFF
PLEASE PROCEED.
A GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE --
CHERRY LEYVA AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS HANNAH BRAG SIDE AND I'M THE
LEGISLATIVE POLICY ANALYST AT
THE CAL STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS THE
NEARLY HALF A MILLION CSU
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
WE ARE THANKFUL FOR SENATOR
GLAZER FOR THE WORK HE'S DONE ON
SB ONE FOUR EIGHT THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM. FOUR YEARS AGO
WHEN SENATOR GLAZER BROUGHT THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE BILL TORE
BOARD CSS A OPPOSE THE BILL.
AT THE TIME WE FELT LIKE THE
TUITION FREEZE AS WELL AS THE
IDEA THAT ONLY THE PRIVILEGED
STUDENTS COULD ACCESS THE
PROGRAM DID NOT HAVE STUDENT
EQUITY AT THE HEART OF THE
PROGRAM.
MAKING OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE
TO ONLY THOSE STUDENTS WITH THE
FINANCIAL ABILITY TO TAKE THEM
AS NON EQUITABLE SOLUTION TO US.
MANY STUDENTS HAVE TO WORK
MULTIPLE JOBS TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES AND MANY TIMES THEIR
<c.cyan>AMILIES. FOR THEM THE IDEA OF</c>
TAKING FIFTEEN UNITS IS NOT A
QUESTION OF WELL OR LAZINESS AS
THE STUDENTS ARE TYPICALLY
WORKING HARDER THAN ANYONE COULD
EVER IMAGINE.
AND AS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTS CSU STUDENTS WAS SUCH
A HIGH LEVEL OF POWER RECIPIENTS
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS AND
UNDER REPRESENTED POPULATIONS
EQUITY IS AN ABSOLUTE PRIORITY
FOR US.
IT'S AND ARE VERY MISSION AS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS WHY WE ARE
SO APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE ON SB FOUR
EIGHT BY SENATOR GLAZER AND HIS
STAFF. TO COME UP WITH
INCENTIVES TO ENABLE ALL
STUDENTS A GOOD FAITH
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE PROGRAMS WITH THE ADDED
INCENTIVES SUMMER TERM GRANTS ON
TRACK PROGRESS GRAMPS TO OFFSET
NON TUITION COSTS.
AND NO TUITION CHARGE FOR
STUDENTS TO TAKE LONGER THAN
FOUR YEARS DUE TO INSTITUTIONAL
FAULT THE BILL NOW ADDRESSES
MANY OF OUR CONCERNS REGARDING
EQUITY.
GOING TO COLLEGE HAS A NUMBER OF
BENEFITS FOR OUR STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY IN THE CAL STATE
SYSTEM.
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR UPWARD
SOCIAL MOBILITY IS CHIEF AMONG
THEM THIS PERSPECTIVE IS
SUPPORTED BY RESEARCH THAT A
SHOWN MANY CAL STATE CAMPUSES
ARE ARE THE NATIONAL LEADERS ON
ENOUGH ENABLING EXCUSE ME.
UPWARD SOCIAL MOBILITY CAL STATE
LA AS THE NUMBER ONE INSTITUTION
TO DO THIS BUT THIS BENEFIT IS
NEVER REALIZED INCIDENTS ARE
ACTUALLY WORSE OFF IF THEY
CANNOT GRADUATE.
IF THE STATE CREATES PROGRAMS
THAT HELP STUDENTS GRADUATE
QUICKER EVEN SMALLER SUBSET TO
STUDENTS THAT HAS AN IMPACT ON
ALL STUDENTS SIMPLY PUT
GRADUATING STUDENTS QUICKER
OPENS UP COURSE BASED.
ACROSS THE BOARD AS WELL AS
ENROLLMENT SOUGHT.
SB ONE FOUR EIGHT SIX TO DO JUST
THIS NOW WITH THE INCENTIVES
INCLUDED NOT ONLY WILL THE
BENEFITS OF THE PROGRAM BE SEEN
BY ALL STUDENTS IN THE SYSTEM.
BUT NOW THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PERSONALLY PARTICIPATE IN THE
STUDENT ERIC SEES ME THIS
PROGRAM IS OPEN TO ALL STUDENTS
WE THANK THE SENATOR FOR HIS
WORK ON THIS AND DRIVE VOTE
TODAY.
THANK YOU MS BURKE STAFF TO
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. TO HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING. TO LEAVE A AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MARIO
GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION --
I DO WANT TO START OFF BY
THINKING SENATOR GLACIER FOR
WORKING WITH US AND SPEAKING
WITH US EARLY ABOUT ADDRESSING
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS.
WE AGREE ON THAT YOU KNOW THERE
IS NO SECRET THE GRADUATION
RATES.
IN CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
ARE LOWER OVERALL -- THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE -- ALTHOUGH
THEY HAVE BEEN IMPROVING --
HOWEVER WE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
AS HAS BEEN STATED THAT NOT ALL
STUDENTS CAN GRADUATE IN FOUR
YEARS THERE ARE GOOD REASONS FOR
THIS MANY STUDENTS HAVE TO WORK.
IN ORDER TO ATTEND SCHOOL --
MANY STUDENTS HAVE FAMILIES TO
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS MAY BE THE
FIRST IN THE FAMILY TO ATTEND
COLLEGE -- STUDENTS ALSO MAY BE
LACKING -- SUFFICIENT MENTORING --
IN A CLIMATE WHERE PART TIME
FACULTY ARE THE NORM.
I THINK WE ALL SUPPORT THE GOAL
OF SB ONE FOUR EIGHT WHICH IS TO
GRADUATE -- TO HELP STUDENTS
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS IF THEY
ARE ABLE.
TO HOWEVER CFA HAS SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT COULD
DISPROPORTIONATELY ADVANTAGE
STUDENTS ALREADY ABLE TO
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS AT THE
EXPENSE OF OTHER STUDENTS AND
THEIR NEEDS.
IN PARTICULAR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS OF COLOR.
THE BILL TARGETS -- THOSE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO TAKE THIRTY UNITS -- OF
CLASSES PER ACADEMIC YEAR THIS
IS FOCUSING ON A VERY NARROW
COMPONENT OF THE PROBLEM WELL
STUDENTS A STRING LONG TOGETHER
CLASSES -- AS THEY'RE ABLE AND
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET --
THEY THESE STUDENTS MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE.
I AM PART TIME FACULTY AT
SACRAMENTO STATE I CAN'T THINK
OF A SINGLE SEMESTER WHERE I
HAVEN'T HAD TO TURN AWAY
STUDENTS BECAUSE THEY'RE
LITERALLY WASN'T A SEED LEFT IN
THE CLASS OR BECAUSE THE CLASS
WAS FULL AND I ALREADY HAD TEN
TO FIFTEEN STUDENTS.
WANTED TO ADD MY CLASS.
IT'S HEART WRENCHING TO TURN
DISTANCE AWAY.
THE PROGRAM THIS PROGRAM AS AS
CREATED COULD BUMP LOW INCOME
STUDENTS FROM CLASSES ADVANTAGES
STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT LOW INCOME --
THROUGH PRIORITY REGISTRATION --
THE STUDENTS HAVE PLENTY OF
FLEXIBILITY AND WHEN THEY COULD
TAKE CLASSES WERE AS LOW INCOME
STUDENTS THAT HAVE TO WORK MAKE.
DO NOT HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY WE
WOULD URGE THE BIRDS LEGISLATURE
ALONG WITH THE CSU TO WORK
TOWARD SOLUTIONS THAT BENEFIT
ALL STUDENTS.
SUCH AS REDUCING THE COST OF
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR ALL
STUDENTS OR OFFERING MORE
CLASSES -- TO HELP STUDENTS MEET
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS AN
INCREASING ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
AND RESOURCES SUCH AS MENTAL
HEALTH COST OF HOUSING AND FOOD
TO HELP THE CSU MORE EFFECTIVELY
HELP STUDENTS ATTAIN THEIR
DEGREE.
WE HAVE SHARED WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE -- THAT IF HE WOULD BE
WILLING TO HAVE ALL OF THE
BENEFITS BOTH FINANCIAL AND
REGISTRATION APPLY TO LOW INCOME
STUDENTS -- THAT WE WOULD REMOVE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY VERY GOOD WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE BEFORE I
OPEN IT UP TO THE COMMITTEE I
JUST LIKE TO SAY CENTER GLAZER
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL -- I AM GOING TO VOTE
YESTERDAY BUT RESERVE THE RIGHT
TO VOTE NO ON THE FLOOR IF WE
DON'T COME A LITTLE FARTHER I DO
STILL WORRY ABOUT SOME OF THE
EQUITY ISSUES.
AND SOME OF THE ISSUES RAISED BY
CFA -- BUT HAPPY TO SUPPORTED
TODAY SO THAT YOU CAN CONTINUE
WORKING ON IT.
OTHERS ON THE IN FROM THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR DORADO.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
I'D LIKE TO SHARE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU HAVE REYES
I'VE.
SPOKEN WITH CENTER GLAZER -- IT
PUTS ME IN FEELS LIKE A BIG
DILEMMA IT'S ALMOST LIKE I'M
CHOOSING SOME OVER OTHERS WHICH
SHOULDN'T BE THE CASE.
IN PUBLIC EDUCATION TO BE
EVERYBODY ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN DEPRIVED.
SO -- I HAVE MORE MORE MEN MORE
QUESTIONS I'M NOT SURE THAT ALL
COULD BE COULD BE ANSWERED BUT
IN PARTICULAR HOW THE CURRENT
PROGRAM.
HAS IMPACTED WHO ARE THE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE BENEFITED FROM
THE CURRENT PROGRAM.
AND HOW DO WE MAKE SURE.
THAT MORE OF THOSE STUDENTS ARE
GETTING THE SAME ACCESS TO THE
CLASSES THAT THEY NEED SO ON THE
ONE HAND I LOVE THE IDEA THAT
MORE STUDENTS WILL BE ABLETO
GRADUATE -- THAT'S FINE I MET
WITH STUDENTS SAW -- AND CAL
STATE IN THAT AREA AND THAT WAS
THEIR BIG ISSUE -- SO I'M REALLY
TORN I BELIEVE THAT A WE HAVE TO
DO ALL WE CAN TO HELP MORE
STUDENTS TO GRADUATE -- BUT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT AND STILL UNSURE
ABOUT ITS IMPACT ON LOW INCOME
ON IN CAL STATE LA I THINK THE
MAJORITY ARE PROBABLY FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
SO THOSE WHO WOULD BENEFIT FROM
YOUR PROPOSAL I BELIEVE A GOOD
NUMBER OF THEM I DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION MAYBE YOU DO WOULD
BENEFIT BUT STILL IS THAT MEAN
THAT WERE.
PUSHING FURTHER BEHIND THOSE WHO
ARE STRUGGLING SO MUCH -- TO TO
GET THROUGH AND AND TO GRADUATE --
IT BACK WHEN I WENT TO SCHOOL IT
WAS.
A GIVEN THAT YOU GRADUATE IN
FOUR YEARS.
RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT AND I JUST
DON'T YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY YET WHAT'S HAPPENED TO
BREAK THAT DOWN -- SO I'M-- I'M
GOING TO VOTE FOR YOUR BILL
TODAY BUT I HAVE MANY UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS.
AND I TO RESPECT A LOT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION --
IS SAYING AND THE ISSUES THAT
THEY RAISED SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
FIGURING THOSE THOSE ISSUES OUT.
THE USER DRAWS -- YES THE CENTER
PM.
THANK YOU AND SORRY GLAZER AYE --
MONTH THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I KNOW THAT --
CERTAINLY TRYING TO IN TERMS OF
TRYING -- TO TO CAN DO TO GET
STUDENTS -- TO GRADUATE IN FOUR
YEARS TO I KNOW THE SYSTEM'S
BEEN WORKING ON THIS AS WELL
BECAUSE CERTAINLY EVERY YEAR AS
SOON CAN'T GRADUATE TO
ESPECIALLY IT'S FOR REASONS IN
THE INSTITUTION -- THAT'S MORE
EXPENSE FOR BOTH.
THE FAMILY AS WELL AS THE ART
OUR STATE AND OUR CSU SYSTEM --
I KNOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
ISSUE BEFORE AND YOU'VE
PRESENTED TO REGIONAL CALIFORNIA --
PROMISE I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS I GUESS -- AND
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT -- THE
PRIORITY REGISTRATION IS
ACTUALLY IN CURRENT LAW BECAUSE
IT'S PART OF WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY
PASSED WITH COFFEE PROBLEMS
CORRECT AND AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT WE HAD THIS THERE IS A THAT
THE BASICALLY THERE THE BILL HAS
TO RENEW THEIR EXTEND THE THIS
IS THIS KIND OF HIGHLIGHT.
IN SOME WAYS CORRECT -- AT LEAST
THE ORIGINAL ONE I MEAN WE'RE
ATTY RIGHT AND SEVEN AND SO.
SO I I DO THINK THAT WE NEED I
THINK THE BIG CONCERN BEFORE AND
YOUR HEARING AID THAT IS AS
ABOUT THE EQUITY ISSUES ALL
RIGHT -- I THINK THE CHALLENGES
WHEN YOU HAVE STUDENTS.
TO OUR AND MORE I GUESS UNSTABLE
CIRCUMSTANCES -- MAY HAVE -- WHO
WHO WHO WHO WHO MAY NOT HAVE THE
KIND OF SUPPORTS WHAT I FEEL
LIKE THEY CAN MAKE A COMMITMENT
THAT THEY WOULD ACTUALLY BECAUSE
THEY MAY BE PULLED AWAY?
JUST MAY HAVE TO GO WORK -- TO
MAKE SOME MONEY -- SUPPORT YOU
KNOW THEIR FAMILY OR OTHER TYPES
OF SITUATIONS -- THE THAT
BECOMES A BIT OF A CHALLENGE FOR
THEM TO COMMIT ST -- GOING TO
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS AND THEN
IF NOW THEY'RE MORE DISADVANTAGE
I THINK THAT'S A CONCERN THAT
YOU.
HEARD SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN LOOK
AT THOSE ISSUES -- BEFORE AND
HOPEFULLY TO SOME DATA WE CAN BE
GATHERED ON THAT -- AS WE LOOK
AT THE PROGRAM OVERALL -- WHEN
IT COMES BACK FOR YOU KNOW FIGHT
MY GUESS EXTENSION OR SOMETHING
BUT -- CERTAINLY I THINK -- THE
WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING THIS BILL
IS -- SOMETHING I CAN SUPPORT
TODAY AND WILL -- AND BUT WE
NEED TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON AND
WHAT HOW THIS IS AFFECTING
VARIOUS SUBGROUPS OF STUDENTS
AND I'M SURE I AM SURE YOU YOU
TO ALSO WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
DATE AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
USER PAN SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I HAVE COMPLETE CONFIDENCE IN
YOU AS AN AUTHOR AND I KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA CONTINUE WORK WITH
THE OTHER SIDE AND DO WHAT'S IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF STUDENTS.
I SEE THIS AND WE'RE GETTING
STUDENTS ARE QUICKER AT THAT
OPENS UP SEATS -- AND FRANKLY I
THOUGHT IT WAS A CO AUTHOR THIS
BILL SO IT DOESN'T HURT YOU I'D
LIKE TO BE AT AS A CO AUTHOR
WHEN WHEN APPROPRIATE.
AND I KNOW YOU CONTINUE WORK
WITH THE OTHER SIDE AND I I KNOW
WHAT'S IN YOUR HEART I KNOW IT'S
ALL ABOUT STUDENT ACCESS AND
SUCCESS SO.
I'M HAPPY SPORTY TODAY AND I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT ON THE FLOORS
WHILE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILK SURVEYS
WHICH LIKE CLOTHES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS -- THERE ARE
SOME MISUNDERSTANDINGS ABOUT THE
ORIGINAL PROMISE PROGRAM.
THE FOCUS ON THAT PROGRAM IS ON
THE LOW INCOME STUDENTS THE
UNDERSERVED THE FIRST AND THEIR
FAMILIES AFFECTED IN THE LAW.
THAT I CAMPUS BASED COMMITTEES
ARE THE ONES THAT.
THE ONLY DIRECTION THAT THEY
GIVE TO THOSE CAMPUS BASED
COMMITTEES THAT THEY MUST GIVE
PRIORITY TO THOSE STUDENTS.
AND THAT ANY OTHER STUDENT
DOESN'T FIT THAT CATEGORY.
I DOES NESTLE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
BE IN THE PROMISE PROGRAM.
THEY HAVE FULL CONTROL OVER WHO
IS ALLOWED IN AND WHO'S NOT AND
THE CRITERIA IS VERY CLEAR.
YOU HAVE TO BE A LOW INCOME
STUDENT.
YOU HAVE -- TO BE UNDER
REPRESENTED.
AND YOU HAVE TO BE A FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENT OR A
TRANSFER STUDENT.
SO THE FOCUS OF THE PROGRAM FROM
THE START HAS ALWAYS BEEN ON THE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE THE MOST NEED
AND IT CONTINUES TO BE.
MY CENTRAL GOAL AND I CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING THAT
INTERFERES WITH THAT.
REGISTRATION FOR CLASSES ON I
THINK ON ALL CAMPUSES IS BASED
ON HOW FAR YOU ARE A LONG AND
GETTING TO A DEGREE.
AND IF YOU'RE A SENIOR AND
YOU'RE NOT IN THE PROMISE
PROGRAM.
I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE THE HIGHEST
REGISTRATION PRIORITY BECAUSE OF
YOUR UNIT COUNT IT'S JUST WHAT
HAPPENS ON THE CAMPUSES IN
GENERAL.
AND SO THE IDEA THAT SOMEHOW
THIS IS GOING TO HOLD BACK
SOMEBODY WHO IS NOT IN THE
PROMISE PROGRAM THAT'S UNDER
REPRESENTED -- POOR IT'S JUST
NOT TRUE.
IT'S JUST NOT TRUE.
NOW DO WE HAVE INSTITUTIONAL
ISSUES ON THE CAMPUS OF MAKING
CLASSES AVAILABLE YES WE DO
THAT'S A BROADER ISSUE.
GOES BEYOND THIS THIS BILL AND
CERTAINLY.
THE ONLY REQUIREMENT OF THIS
BILL IS THAT IT CREATES
INCENTIVES FOR THE CAMPUS TO
AVOID THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
TO PROVIDE THOSE CLASSES IT AT
NO COST.
BUT THE CSU IS SUCH A IT'S SUCH
A MIRACLE PLACE FOR OUR OUR OUR
LOW INCOME KIDS YOU KNOW THAT
75% OF OUR STUDENTS AT THE CSU
GRADUATE SEES ME QUALIFY FOR
FINANCIAL AID.
BY DEFINITION 75% ARE OF THE
LOWER INCOME.
THAT FITS THE CRITERIA THE
PROMISE PROGRAM LAST YEAR 60% OF
OUR GRADUATES FROM THE CSU OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND FIRST IN
THEIR FAMILY TO GRADUATE IT'S AN
IT'S A MIRACLE PLACE. FOR SO
MANY TO GIVE THEM THIS GREAT
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY.
I DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING THAT
DOES ANYTHING BUT SUPPORT THAT
CONTINUED WONDERFUL MIRACLE FROM
CONTINUING OKAY -- AND I THINK
THAT THIS BILL IS NARROWLY
FOCUSED -- BUT I CERTAINLY FROM
THE COULD CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED EARLIER -- I AYE ARE WERE
LINES ON WHAT WE WANT TO
ACCOMPLISH.
THESE ARE THESE ARE SMALL STEPS
THAT WE'RE TAKING OUT OF A
LARGER DESIRE TO HAVE THESE KIDS
BE SUCCESSFUL AND NOT HAVE TO
WASTE THOSE.
HIGH SCHOOL SCORES THEIR COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS THE LOANS ALL THOSE
THINGS.
BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT FOLKS.
THIS YEAR TENS OF THOUSANDS ARE
GONNA DROP OUT.
WITH ALL THAT DATA IF THEY HAVE
IT AND NOT HAVE A DEGREE WE GOT
IT WE GOT TO DO BETTER I KNOW
THE FACULTY AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND STUDENT
LEADERSHIP IS COMMITTED TO
MAKING A DIFFERENCE THERE.
AND THESE ARE PART OF OUR
EFFORTS TO TRY TO DO THAT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER WE HAVE
A MOTION.
SO MOVED THANK YOU SENATOR WILK
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM THREE SB ONE FOUR EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS IS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WILKHI WILK I CHANGE.
DUE TO WRESTLE HI LATE THAT TO
WRESTLE AYE GLAZER AYE GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN THANK YOU CENTER
GLAZER [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO DOCTOR PAN OF SIR LEYVA HAS
TO TO GO SIGN INTO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE SO IF YOU COULD
PERCENT ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
[inaudible]
TWO NINE SEVEN THANK YOU
ONCE HERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SHARE IN NUMBERS CENTERS UP FOR
DECADES SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
STRUGGLE TO MEET SUMMER
CONSTRUCTION DEADLINES HEAD OF
STUDENTS ARRIVING FOR CLASSES IN
THE FALL OFTEN RELAYING AND
RESULTING IN ADDITIONAL COSTS
THE LAYS IN THIS PLACE STUDENTS.
THE FIRST -- WEEKS OR EVEN
MONTHS OF CONTRACTOR TO BE UNDER
A NEWLY AWARDED CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTOR FOCUSED ON
PRELIMINARY WORK ATTRACT
AWARDING SUBCONTRACTS.
MAKING SHOP DRAWINGS IN ORDERING
APPROVED MATERIALS AND EQUIPMENT.
AND ANYONE'S BEEN INVOLVED IN
TRYING TO DO CONSTRUCTION THAT
IS THAT.
YOU DON'T OFTENTIMES LIKE WELL
GEE NOTHING'S HAPPENING ACTUALLY
A LOT OF STUFF IS HAPPENING --
THE AUTHORITY TO WARD CON
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS PRIOR TO
STATE ARCHITECT APPROVAL
CURRENTLY EXIST FOR DESIGN BUILD
PROJECTS IN FOR K. TO TWELVE
LEASE.
LEASEBACK PROJECTS BUT NOT FOR
TRADITIONAL COMPETITIVELY BID
PROJECTS SB TWO NINETY SEVEN
WOULD ALLOW SCHOOLS AND
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO
WARD CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS.
BUT NOT PERFORM CONSTRUCTION
PRIOR TO RECEIVING PLAN APPROVAL
FROM THE STATE ARCHITECT THE
STREAMLINING SUMMER CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS.
BE ABLE TO WARD SUBCONTRACTING
COMPLETE OTHER PRELIMINARY WORK
IN THE METRIC WINTER MONTHS WHEN%
CONSTRUCTION WORK TO SLOW MEANS
BETTER PRICES CAN BE ATTAINED.
AND SUBSEQUENT SUMMER
CONSTRUCTION WORK WILL BE BETTER
PLANNED MATERIALS WOULD BE
DELIVERED IN READY FOR
CONSTRUCTION.
SB TWO NINETY SEVEN ALSO ALLOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AVOID COSTLY
DELAYS FOR MAINTAINING STUDENT
SAFETY IS PROVIDED BY THE FIELD
ACT.
SB TWO NINETY SEVEN SUPPORTED BY
SCHOOL FACILITY PRESS-PROFESSIONALS AND CONSTRUCTION
COMPANIES WOULD CODIFY ALLEGE
THE RECOMMENDATION MADE BY TASK
FORCE COMMISSION BY THE DIVISION
OF STATE ARCHITECTS.
ARE TODAY I HAVE WITH ME DICK
HOW ONE OF THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION MANAGERS
AND INTO DELLA WITH COALITION
FOR SCHOOL HOUSING.
AT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TO ANSWER ANY TAKEN
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. TO KAREN
MEMBERS IAN BUT DEAL WITH THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING -- IN SUPPORT FOR ALL
THE REASONS THAT THE THAT THE
MEMBER HAS -- OUTLINED I THOUGHT
THAT WAS A IT WAS A GOOD SUMMARY --
WE WE THINK THAT BEING ABLE TO
LOCK IN -- THESE --
PRECONSTRUCTION SERVICES DOES
DEFINITELY PROVIDE A ITS
CERTAINTY -- IN THE PROCESS IN
IN MANY CASES.
AND AND THE CONCERN ABOUT --
DRESSING PRICE ESCALATION IN AND
BEING ABLE TO STAGE OF THOSE
THINGS A VERY IMPORTANT PIECE
RIGHT NOW AS I THINK WE'RE IS IS
EVERYONE KNOWS IT'S A IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT -- ISSUE IN IN IN IN
EVERY SECTOR -- WE WOULD LIKE.
TO MENTION THAT -- WITH REGARD
TO ANY CONCERNS -- ABOUT CHANGE
ORDERS AND THINGS LIKE THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT THE THE EXISTING --
PRE QUALIFICATION REQUIREMENTS
ARE -- ARE YOU KNOW DESIGNED TO
DRESS -- THOSE TYPES OF ISSUES
SO WITH THAT -- AGAIN CASH IS IN
FULL SUPPORT AND WE'RE HERE --
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR
PROVIDE ANY RESOURCES -- TO YOU
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME HERE
TODAY -- THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ALREADY TRUSTED SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO AWARD CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS
AHEAD OF STATE ARCHITECT
APPROVAL OF DRAWINGS AND
SPECIFICATIONS IF THEY USE THEIR
LEASE BACK OR DESIGN BUILD
AUTHORITY SO THIS IS NOT A NEW.
PROCESS WE WANT TO AND I
ACTUALLY SERVED ON THAT TASK
FORCE THAT WAS MENTIONED WE WANT
TO GIVE THIS TOOL TO THE
DISTRICTS FOR THE PERHAPS.
THIRTY OR FORTY THOUSAND
CONTRACTS THAT ARE AWARDED EACH
YEAR FOR THE MORE ROUTINE KINDS
OF PROJECTS NEW WINDOWS AROUND
THE CAMPUS FOR BETTER ENERGY
EFFICIENCY RE ROOFING -- FOR THE
FLOORING -- CAMPUS WIDE THESE
ARE THE MEAT AND POTATOES KIND
OF PROJECTS THAT ARE WARDED
TRADITIONAL HARD BID -- BASED ON
PLANS AND SPECS STAMP BY
PROFESSIONAL ARCHITECTS -- THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW SOME THAT
PRELIMINARY WORK TO BE DONE KIND
OF STRATEGICALLY IF THE DISTRICT
WANTED TO AWARD THE CONTRACT
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW SUMMERS ARE
GETTING SHORTER AND SHORTER.
IN THE SCHOOL VACATION PERIOD SO
IF WE COULD GET ALL THOSE
SUBCONTRACTS AWARDED MATERIALS
AND EVERYTHING STAGE THEN AS
SOON AS THE STATE ARCHITECT HAS
APPROVED THE PLANS AND SPECS AND
THE BELL RINGS IN THE KIDS RUN
OUT.
THEN OUR CONSTRUCTION CRAFTSMAN
CAN COME RIGHT IN AND HAVE A
MORE SUCCESSFUL PROJECT HIGHER
QUALITY PROJECT WITHOUT RUSHING
IN AND TRYING TO DO -- QUICK
FIXES SO THAT'S THE IDEA I
REALLY LIKE THAT THE BILL
PROTECTS THE FIELD ACT
REQUIREMENT THAT NO CONSTRUCTION.
CAN TAKE PLACE UNTIL THE STATE
ARCHITECT HAS APPROVED THOSE
DRAWINGS AND SPECIFICATIONS.
SO I DON'T THINK THE DISTRICTS
WILL USE THIS TOOL ON EVERY ONE
OF THOSE FIFTY THOUSAND PROJECTS
EACH YEAR BUT I TRUST THEM AND
THEIR ARCHITECTS AND THEIR
ATTORNEYS. TO CHOOSE WHICH
PROJECTS WOULD HAVE A GOOD FIT
FOR THIS IDEA OF EARLY
PRELIMINARY WORK.
I ALSO TRUST THEM HAVING BEEN A
BUILDER FOR THEM FOR YEARS -- TO
FIGURE OUT GOOD LANGUAGE PROJECT
BY PROJECT TO MAKE SURE THAT
CHANGE ORDERS ARE FAIRLY
ADDRESSED -- IF THERE ARE --
CHANGES THAT ARE REQUIRED THAT
WORK REFLECTED IN THE BID
DOCUMENTS SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT I'LL BE GLAD TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SIR OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
OKAY COME ON UP.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MARC CHRISTIAN WITH
THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
MEASURE. TO IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY IN THE CONSTRUCTION
OF SCHOOL FACILITIES THE
MODERNIZATION OF SCHOOL
FACILITIES FOR NOT QUITE IN
SUPPORT YET WE'RE WORKING WITH
THE SPONSOR. TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERN WE HAVE IN THAT CONCERN
IS ONE THAT -- WE BELIEVE THIS
POTENTIALLY COULD INCREASE THE
ARCHITECTS FINANCIAL RISK RIGHT
NOW.
CONSTRUCTION IS BASED UPON THE
APPROVED.
SAID OF CONSTRUCTION DOCUMENTS
APPROVED BY THE DIVISION OF THE
STATE ARCHITECT UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL BIDDING WILL TAKE PLACE
ON THOSE PLANS SUBMITTED TO TSA.
AND NOT YET APPROVED IF THE
APPROVED DOCUMENTS FROM DSA.
HAVE A HIGHER COST OF
CONSTRUCTION WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT HIGHER COST IS
NOT.
PUT ON TO THE DESK OF THE
ARCHITECT THROUGH A CHANGE ORDER
BECAUSE AGAIN AS IT IS TODAY
IT'S THE APPROVED SET OF
DOCUMENTS.
THAT IS THE COST OF CONSTRUCTION
THAT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WE DON'T WANT
THIS TO CREATE A PROCESS WHERE.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO HAVE THE
CONTRACTOR OR TRY TO HAVE THE
ARCHITECT TAKE ON THIS
ADDITIONAL COST OF CONSTRUCTION
THAT RESULTS FROM DSA REVIEW AND
APPROVAL OF THOSE PLANS.
AND WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORED TO
ACHIEVE THAT LANGUAGE THANK YOU
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIR OTHERS
IN PEER SUPPORT.
ON THE WITH THE SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL BUILDERS EXCHANGE ON
BEHALF OF OUR ELEVEN HUNDRED
MEMBER COMPANIES MANY OF WHOM
HAVE -- EDUCATIONAL FACILITY --
DIVISIONS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY VERY GOOD WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
CENTER PARISH LIKE TO CLOSE YES
WHEN I VOTE WONDERFUL SOMEONE
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
GLAZER -- MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FIVE SB TWO NINETY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
BY LEYVA AYE WILK AYE WILK I
CHIANG WHO ASAL.
WRESTLE AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN.
AND I THE BILL HAS FOUR OF THAT
BILLS FOR VOTES WE WILL -- KEEP
IT OPEN FOR THOSE WHO ARE NOT
HERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT -- MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN TURN IT OVER TO YOU SO
THAT WE CAN HEAR THE LAST BILL.
THE WRITER NEXT ITEM WILL BE
ITEM FOR SB TWO NINETY ONE BY
CENTER LEYVA THE RECOMMENDATION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR LEYVA THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIR GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL MUCH APPRECIATED. FOR
NEARLY SIXTY YEARS THE MASTER
PLAN FOR HIGHER EDUCATION HAS
GUARANTEED THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO COLLEGE.
MOST STUDENTS NEARLY TWO POINT
TWO MILLION ANNUALLY INCLUDING
THE VAST MAJORITY OF FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS OF COLOR.
ACCESS OUR PROMISE TO HIGHER
EDUCATION THROUGH ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
BY MYSELF CERTAIN OF MY COLLEGE
CAREER AT MOUNT SAN ANTONIO
COLLEGE AND WHILE THE CALIFORNIA.
ALTHOUGH THE MASTER PLAN
PROVIDES A COMMITMENT TO COLLEGE
ACCESS STATE HIGHER EDUCATION
FUNDING POLICY REINFORCES DEEPLY
CONCERNING INEQUITIES FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
CALLER COMMUNICABLE EDGE.
EXCUSE ME CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
COLLEGES SERVE THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS IN
THE STATE YET THEY RECEIVE THE
LOWEST PER STUDENT FUNDING LEVEL
OF ANY OF THE STATE'S EDUCATION
SEGMENTS.
AS A STATE WE HAVE MADE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS IN REMOVING
FINANCIAL BARRIERS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE GRANT AND ITS
EFFORTS TO MAKE TO YOUR COLLEGE
IT TWO YEARS OF COLLEGE FREE.
APPROXIMATELY 43% OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE THEIR
TUITION WAVED UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE GRANT.
EVEN SO.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE OFTEN THE
LEAST AFFORDABLE OPTION FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WHEN THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE IS FACTORED
IN.
THE REAL COST OF COLLEGE IS MORE
THAN JUST TUITION.
IT INCLUDES NON TUITION EXPENSES
SUCH AS HOUSING TEXTBOOKS
TRANSPORTATION AND FOOD WHICH
CAN EXCEED NINETEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THESE HIGH NON TUITION COSTS
MAKE SUCCEEDING IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ESPECIALLY DIFFICULT FOR
LOWER INCOME STUDENTS.
NEED BASED FINANCIAL AID TO
COVER NON TUITION COSTS IS SO
LIMITED FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS THAT IT IS OFTEN MORE
EXPENSIVE FOR THE LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS TO ATTEND.
A CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THEN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA I PERSONALLY FOUND
THAT SHOCKING WHEN I FOUND OUT.
THIS LACK OF AFFORDABILITY IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND WE OWE OUR
FUTURE LEADERS SO MUCH MORE.
SB TWO NINETY ONE CREATES THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM TO MAKE A
MEANINGFUL COMMITMENT TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY.
MANY COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
HAVE TO SUPPORT MORE -- BALLOTS
WORKING MULTIPLE JOBS TO MAKE
ENDS MEET SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES
ALL WHILE PURSUING THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION GOALS.
RESEARCH HAS ALSO SHOWN THAT
THIS ADDITIONAL SOURCE OF STRESS
CAN LEAD TO LOWER ACADEMIC --
PERFORMANCE AND HIGHER DROPOUT
RATES THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
COLLEGE FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM
WOULD HELP STUDENTS REDUCE
STUDENT LOAN DEBT AND THE NEED
FOR MULTIPLE JOBS WILL WORK
WHILE ALLOWING THEM TO COMPLETE
THE PROGRAMS ON TIME. TO AND
VERY SIGNIFICANT AND MORE
EQUITABLE INVESTMENT AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES STUDENTS
FINANCIALLY PACKAGES MUST
SUPPORT THE TOTAL COST OF
COLLEGE.
UNTIL COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO MORE FINANCIAL
AID TO HELP WITH NANTWICH
TUITION COSTS.
A COMPLETE COLLEGE PROMISE IN
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT BE ACHIEVED.
HERE WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS
VALERIE JOHNSON PRESIDENT OF
CRAFTON HILLS COLLEGE STUDENTS
SENATE.
AND JOHN LONG BILL PRESIDENT OF
THE SAM BIRD IN A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AND SOME OF OUR
STUDENTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
WHOEVER WANTS TO START PLEASE
PROCEED.
LARA MATTOON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS WITH THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL -- I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS I'D LIKE TO RESERVE
THE BALANCE OF TIME TO HEAR FROM
OUR STUDENTS IN COLLEGE LEADERS
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS VALERIE JOHNSON
I'M A STUDENT AT CRAFTING HILL
COLLEGE -- WHERE I STUDY
POLITICAL SCIENCE AND SOCIAL
SCIENCES AND I'M ALSO STUDENT
ADVOCATE WITH RICE A STUDENT LED
ORGANIZATION FIGHTING TO RESTORE
THE PROMISE OF PUBLIC EDUCATE
EDUCATION IN?
CALIFORNIA -- AS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT WHO HAS HAD TO
NAVIGATE THE FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM LARGELY ON MY OWN I'VE
LEARNED THAT THE MAIN SOURCE OF
THE COLLEGE COSTS THAT I HAVE.
COME TO FACE IS NOT TUITION BUT
EVERYTHING ELSE -- SO LIKE 46%
OF OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS I RECEIVE NEED BASED
FINANCIAL AID.
AND THAT COVERS MY TUITION COSTS
BUT WHEN YOU FACTOR IN NON
TUITION COSTS -- OF ATTENDING
COLLEGE LIKE BOOKS
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING AND FOOD
THE TOTAL COST TO ATTEND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAN SOMETIMES
EXCEED NINETEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
A SEMESTER I WAS WORKING THREE
JOBS ALL PARTICIPATING IN
STUDENT GOVERNMENT AND TAKING A
FIFTEEN UNIT COURSE LOAD SPREAD
OUT BETWEEN TWO DIFFERENT
COLLEGES.
I CAME CLOSE TO DROPPING MY FULL
TIME STATUS JUST SO THAT I COULD
QUIT MAYBE EVEN ONE OF MY JOBS
AND FOCUS ON MY SCHOOL WORK.
I WAS OVERWHELMED I WAS
DESPERATE AND I WAS WORKING SO
HARD BECAUSE I WANTED TO SERVE
MY COMMUNITY AND PREPARE TO
TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY.
BUT JUGGLING MULTIPLE JOBS AT
THE SAME TIME MADE THE WORKLOAD
UNSUSTAINABLE.
SO THIS IS NOT UNCOMMON AT ALL
AND NON TUITION COSTS A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAN BE SO HIGH
THAT SOME STUDENTS TAKE SEVERAL
YEARS TO COMPLETE.
AND CALIFORNIA HAS THE LOWEST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TUITION IN THE
NATION AND NEARLY HALF STUDENTS
PAY NO TUITION WHICH IS REALLY
GREAT.
BUT IT ISN'T ENOUGH WHEN
TEXTBOOKS RENT FOOD CHILD CARE
AND MORE PRESENT THE LARGEST AND
MOST DAUNTING AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES.
THANKS TO RESEARCH FROM
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS WE CAN NOW SAY FOR
CERTAIN THAT AFTER FACTORING
TOTAL COSTS IN OF ATTENDANCE.
AND GRANT AID THE NET COST OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS ACTUALLY MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT THE SENATOR
MENTIONED -- EVERY STUDENT WHO
WISHES TO ATTEND COLLEGE AND
PURSUE THEIR EDUCATION
REGARDLESS OF THEIR INCOME OR
FAMILY HISTORY OR WHETHER THEY
BEGIN AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DESERVES THE OPPORTUNITY. TO DO
SO SB TWO NINETY ONE IS
ESSENTIAL TO PROVIDING EQUITY TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
HELPING STUDENTS REACH
COMPLETION OF THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS.
WHETHER THEY DO THAT TO OBTAIN A
CERTIFICATE TO TRANSFER TO A
FOUR YEAR INSTITUTION TO RECEIVE
VOCATIONAL TRAINING OR ENHANCE
THEIR PERSONAL KNOWLEDGE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ENROLL MORE
INCUR LOW INCOMES DOING STAND AT
SEE MORE LOW INCOME PELL GRANT
RECIPIENTS AND CSU UC AND
NONPROFIT COLLEGES COMBINED.
AND WE OWE IT TO THOSE STUDENTS
TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HELP
THEM COMPLETE AND RIGHT NOW THE
BEST THING FOR THEM IS OFFERED
THEM SUPPORT IN NON TUITION
COSTS LIKE IS PROPOSED IN THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME MY
NAME IS I USUALLY YOUNG BLOOD
AND I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHICH
REPRESENTS THE TWO POINT ONE
MILLION STUDENTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM.
ON AVERAGE IT TAKES A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT FIVE POINT TWO
YEARS TO GRADUATE A TRANSFER
FROM THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM THE TUITION AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM IS THE
LOWEST IN THE NATION.
BUT THE COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
THE TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT IT'S
ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND IN A
REPORT DONE BY THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS.
DOCTOR OUT NINE REGIONS IN
CALIFORNIA COMPARING THE LOCAL
YOU SEE SEE ISSUES AND
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE IT
SHOWS.
THAT IT WAS MORE TRANSIT TO TEND
TO CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN A FOUR YEAR INSTITUTE ONE OF
THE BIGGEST FACTORS FOR THIS.
EIGHT FOUR THIS IS THE EIGHT
THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS MAKE UP TWO
THIRDS OF THIS COLLEGE STUDENTS
IN THE STATE YET CURRENTLY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
RECEIVED 7% OF THECAL GRANT
FUNDING.
AND UNLIKE UC AND CSU SYSTEM.
WE DO NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
OFFER INSTITUTIONAL EIGHT WHICH
LEAVES OUR STUDENTS WORKING LONG
HOURS. TO COVER THIS NEED OR
SIMPLY GOING WITHOUT A RECENT
STUDY PUT OUT BY THE WHOLE LAB
SHOWED THAT FORTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS SURVEYED 50% WERE FOOD
AND SECURE 60% WERE HOUSING IN
SECURE AND 19% WERE HOMELESS IN
THE LAST YEAR.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS NEED
TO GREATER INVESTMENT IN THE
FINANCIAL AID THAT IS OFFERED
ESPECIALLY FOR MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS AND THAT IS WHY THE
STUDENTS IN IT FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB. TWO NINETY ONE
ONE MANAGE.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
JOHN LONG WILL PRESIDENT OF THE
SAN MARINO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT RATHER BOARD OF
TRUSTEES.
AND I CAN'T HELP BUT NOTICE
THINGS HAVE CHANGED A LOT SINCE
TWO DECADES AGO WHEN I CAME UP
HERE TO THE ASSEMBLY. FOR ONE
THING THE PEOPLE GIVING
TESTIMONY NO LONGER HAVE PIECES
OF PAPER.
AS MUCH IN USING IPHONES IN THE
SENATORS SEEM A LOT YOUNGER BUT
DOES.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT IS.
IN ANY WITH THIS MONTH THE NEWS
IS FOCUSED ON WEALTHY PARENTS
WILLING TO DO JUST ABOUT
ANYTHING LEGAL OR OTHERWISE. TO
ENSURE THEIR KIDS AN IVY LEAGUE
EDUCATION.
WE ONLY THE WEALTHIEST OTHERS
HAVE THE MEANS TO BUY OUR
CHILDREN.
THERE STE FUTURES.
BUT ALL OUR STUDENTS DESERVE
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION
IS THAT THEY WILL NEED TO CHIEF
SOCIAL MOBILITY AND ECONOMIC
SECURITY.
THAT'S WHY CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
PROVIDES.
OUR STUDENTS WITH THE KEYS TO
UNLOCK ECONOMIC PROSPERITY.
WE ARE THE LARGEST WORKFORCE AND
TRANSFER PROVIDER IN THE NATION.
THIS SYSTEM.
REPRESENTS OUR BEST CHANCE TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF MOST STUDENTS
AND EMPLOYERS WE'RE IN
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WE SERVE NEARLY TWO POINT TWO
MILLION STUDENTS ANNUALLY.
CALIFORNIA POLICY MAKERS HAVE
WORKED HARD TO ENSURE THAT
TUITION.
IS NOT A BARRIER FOR STUDENTS
THAT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
WE OFFER THE LOWEST FEES IN THE
NATION FORTY SIX DOLLARS PER
UNIT AND WAIVE FEES FOR NEARLY
HALF OF ALL STUDENTS.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE GRANT.
YET FOR FAR TOO MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS THE STRUGGLE TO PAY
THEIR NON TUITION COSTS.
COMPARED TO TRADITIONAL STUDENTS
WHO ATTEND UC AND CSU SYSTEMS
WERE NEARLY 40% OF THE
UNDERGRADUATES RECEIVE THE CAL
GRANT.
LITTLE GRANT AID IS AVAILABLE TO
HELP COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
COVER THE NINE TUITION COSTS
WHICH HAVE ALREADY BEEN
DESCRIBED YOU AS AND HOW HEAVY
THEY ARE.
BECAUSE SO LITTLE GRANT IS
AVAILABLE TO COVER -- TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS TO
COVER THEIR TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE IT'S ACTUALLY MORE
EXPENSIVE FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AS HAS ALREADY BEEN
NOTED BUT I THINK IT'S WORTH
REPEATING.
IT'S MORE EXPENSIVE FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS TO ATTEND THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES
[inaudible]
THEN.
TO ATTEND THE CLOSEST UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
SENATE BILL TWO NINETY ONE WOULD
CORRECT THIS INEQUITY AND CREATE
A NEW PROGRAM.
A NEW GRANT PROGRAM TO HELP OUR
LOW INCOME STUDENTS COVER THEIR
TOTAL COST TO ATTEND AND
SUCCEEDED OR COLLEGES.
THIS WOULD HELP STUDENTS
ELIMINATE LOAN DEBT IN REDUCE
EXCESSIVE WORK OBLIGATIONS
GIVING THEM THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED TO COMPLETE THEIR PROGRAMS
ON TIME.
IS COLLEGES WE UNDERSTAND OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS.
SB TRUE NINETY ONE WOULD ENSURE
THAT COLLEGES IMPLEMENT EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES.
THAT SUPPORT STUDENTS LIKE.
DUAL ENROLLMENT EARLY OUT
REACHED AYE SCHOOLS BASIC SKILLS
REFORMS AND GUIDED PATHWAYS WERE
DOING THOSE THINGS IN OUR
DISTRICT AND AND MOST DISTRICTS
DO.
COLLEGES WOULD ALSO BE REQUIRED
TO ENSURE STUDENTS COMPLETE
THEIR STAFFS OUR CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT APPLICATION IN DRAW
DOWN AS MUCH EXISTING FEDERAL
AND STATE GRANTED AS POSSIBLE.
SB NINETY ONE INSURERS A
MEANINGFUL COMMITMENT TO COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY FOR OUR STUDENTS
AND WOOD I WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
VOIGTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY ANY
OTHERS THE ONE ADD ON NAME
ORGANIZATION IN.
IF THE SUPPORTED.
MORNING TONY RICE ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
AWESOME LET'S RECAP THE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS AND THEY HAVE THE COAST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
RANCHO SANTIAGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MARK MCDONALD MCCALLUM
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE FOOT
HEALED THE ANSWER KERN PERALTA.
SAN DIEGO AND SAN FRANCISCO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS AS
WELL AS ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE FACULTY
GUILDHALL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
IF YOU.
WERE SICK AND SALAS WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THE DAHLIA CAME WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST HERE IN
SUPPORT.
CAN LUIS REPRESENTING A SPEAR
AND THAT AND THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YEARS AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MANY B. AS
REPRESENTING THE SAN JOSE
EVERGREEN COMMUNICATIVE STRICT.
VERY MUCH TO SUPPORT AND ALSO
LET'S SEE MY FORMER COLLEAGUE
DONALD.
VINCENT WHERE A MERGER WITH THE
WIRING GROUP ON BEHALF
CONNECTION SUPPORT.
MICHELLE MCANDREW IT ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS
IN SUPPORT.
EDWIN LOMBARD REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE AND THE BLACK BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME SAMI
GONZALEZ AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO NINETY ONE I GO TO
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE AND
HEARING FROM A PEER OF MINE IS A
COLLEGE STUDENT IT IS.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP US A LOT --
I'M AN ANIMAL SCIENCE MAJORS SO
THAT MAJOR ALONE JUST TAKES A
LOT OF MONEY SO I'M HOPING THAT --
THAT THIS BILL GETS PASSED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
AOSHIMA SAKE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING BRIANNA BRENT ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA AS COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
RIOS COMMUNICORP DISTRICT IN THE
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNICORP
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING -- JAKE BREMNER ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
NICOLAS TOWERS ON BEHALF OF
SANTA MONICA COLLEGE AND LONG
BEACH CITY COLLEGE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS REGION CORPUS SEMI
SALEM BUT ALSO AN ALUMNI FROM
THE SENATE COMMITTEE COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
AS BETWEEN AND ONE GOOD MORNING
ERIKA ROMERO BEHALF THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING BRIAN DALY A CITY
COLLEGE STUDENT SAN FRANCISCO
CITY COLLEGE IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND EUROPE PRESENTING STUDENTS
MAKING A CHANGE THANK.
YOU.
EVERYONE MY NAME IS NIKKI HALF
FILLED I'M A FULL TIME STUDENT
AT CITY COLLEGE OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND ALSO REPRESENTING STUDENTS
MAKING A CHANGE AND I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DENISE CASTER
NAY I WANT TO HEAR OF ANY
THREATS MAKING A CHANGE AND I'M
FOR SUPPORT.
HANNAH BRAG START WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION -- WE
HAVE A SUPPORT OF AMENDED
POSITION WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
SENATOR WITH HER IMPORTANT
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE BUT
WOULD LIKE TO SEE CSU STUDENTS
INCLUDED AS WELL THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT -- HE SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
THAT'S PROBABLY GREAT WISE
CHOICE.
OKAY BILLS REMOVE LIKE TO PULL
BACK RIGHT NOW -- FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
I THINK THIS IS TREMENDOUS THIS
IS EXACTLY GETS TO THE HEART OF
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
GET OF THE COLLEGE DEGREES.
IT'S STRANGE TO SEE THE FLIP
FROM.
TUITION BEING THE ISSUED TO NOW
HOW DO I SUPPORT MYSELF FULL I'M
GOING TO SCHOOL.
AND AGAIN YOU KNOW WE THINK OF
WHAT IT WAS LIKE FOR MYSELF
GOING TO SCHOOL AND YEAH I HAD
TO GET SOME LOANS I HAD TO WORK
HERE AND THERE I DID DO THOSE
SORTS OF THINGS TO HOBBLE
COBBLING TOGETHER BUT IT WASN'T
ANYTHING LIKE WHAT IT'S TODAY SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL CENTER
LEYVA AND EVERYBODY ELSE WHO'S.
IN SUPPORT AND FIGHTING FOR THIS.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION WHICH
IS SAID DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF CENTER LATELY
FOR YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
CLEARLY MEMBERS TIMES HAVE
CHANGED AND IT'S OUR JOB TO
CHANGE WITH THOSE TIMES IT'S OUR
JOB TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS.
I THINK ABOUT WHEN I WAS A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT AND I
WORKED ONE JOB NOT THREE WE HEAR
THAT THE ECONOMY IS BOOMING BUT
WHO IS IT REALLY BOOMING FOR THE
REASON THAT I WAS ABLE TO WORK
ONE JOB AND GO TO COLLEGE IS
BECAUSE I HAD A GOOD.
UNION JOB AND PROBABLY YOUR
THREE JOBS ARE MINIMUM WAGE JOBS
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO
BUT HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE WE
CAN WORK ON HELPING MAKE SURE
THAT OUR STUDENTS.
CAN ATTAIN THE SUCCESS THEY NEED
AND GRANTS ARE SO MUCH BETTER
THAN LOANS BECAUSE WE ALSO DON'T
WANT TO SEND OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
OUT INTO THE WORLD WITH A BUNCH
OF DEBT.
SO MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
IN WITHOUT THE CLERK COULD READ
THE ROLE ITEM FOR SB TWO NINETY
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE WELL.
WILK I CHANGE.
DO ASAL HI GOOD SO I GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE HAN HI CAN I
OKAY AS FIVE ZERO SO THE THE
BILL IS APPLE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN --
FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON AND TURN
THE GAVEL BACK OVER TO MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS WE'RE NOT GOING TO
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND
LESSER IS ANYTHING THAT ANYONE
WOULD LIKE REMOVED FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
OKAY.
OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS SB
FIFTY TWO CENTER ATKINS AND SB
THREE SIXTEEN AS AMENDED BY
RUBIO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR PAN MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK WILK I CHANGE THE
VESSEL I DO THAT SO I GLAZER
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN -- FOR
SENATOR REQUIRED TO ADD ON THANK
YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR COMING TODAY
IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM ONE SB ONE THIRTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR OF THE HI
SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I'D.
SEVEN THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM THREE SB ONE FORTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
FIVE ZERO CHIANG.
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE I'D. SIX SIX
ZERO THAT BILL IS ALSO OUT.
I'M SORRY IT IS ON CALL WAITING
FOR SENATOR CHIANG [inaudible]
THIS CALL.
ITEM FOUR SB TWO NINETY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE.
VICE CHAIR VOTING I FIVE ZERO
CHIANG MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE.
THE ON CALL.
ITEM FIVE SB TWO NINETY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING I BY SERVING I FIVE ZERO
CHIANG MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I BELIEVE THAT BILL OPEN
AS WELL THANK YOU.
HE SAID.
WHEN WE CAN CONSENT CALENDAR --
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING I FIVE ZERO CHIANG
MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE
MEN
SECRETARY IF YOU'LL PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SO ITEM THREE SB ONE FORTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D SAID. SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT.
ITEM FOR SB TWO NINETY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING. NINE
SIX ZERO CHIANG CHANGE. SEVEN
ZERO THAT BILLS OUT AS WELL.
ITEM FIVE SB TWO NINETY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I AM VICE CHAIR VOTING I
SIX ZERO CHANG.
CHANG ON ONE SEVEN ZERO THAT
VOTERS OUT CAN BILLS OUT.
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
SIX ZERO CHIANG.
CHING AYE. SEVEN ZERO THE
CONSOLE CONSENT COUNTERS
CONFIRMED AS WELL THANK YOU
EVERYONE HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY WE
ARE ADJOURNED